how come resume a little back welcome to
infamous second son part who gives a
[ __ ] we have television brofist now
don't know what we're gonna do about
that uh someone's shooting me where's
our objective oh yeah it's one enou
another one of those where you can
choose if we want to be good or bad
objective I kind of wit like want to do
a second playthrough of this just doing
all the evil evil ones it seemed that
most people pick to be evil in this game
uh so I'm glad I picked uh pick nice so
you know oh god I switched power oh well
it's really hard to find televisions in
this game I don't understand why they
were thinking really there
brofist speaking of televisions
goddamnit do they work can I drink from
them
la oh alright well start the mission
whatever gene open up its me hey Gus it
why'd you move to the clubhouse yeah I'm
um I'm ready let's rock and roll man
well no you're gonna rock and roll I'm
gonna stick to the shadows what you know
stealth yes
tell right stuff all right stealth
what's the plan uh you know all those
suspected bio terrorists we freed from
the DUP well I actually remember it
being a rescue party of one but go on I
turns out the curent gangs been rounding
them up and holding them at a
construction site near here they're
planning to sell went back to the TV
great why don't we go get them well
don't worry I'm sending my friends to
meet you there and my friends I hope you
mean an army of Archangels and not
Melvin and Lenny from your D&D group I
don't have it seriously you've got
lighten up I want to play D&D a I never
played it seems fun I'm just saying it's
another cool thing uh which I knew for a
while
but I just haven't said it it says the
voice actor for this game I literally
I'm here where your friends oh they're
on their way but you need to check the
interior of the site and they're not so
good animator angels are claustrophobic
great anything else I should know about
my backup they're not so great in water
either well that makes two of us
that's true the voice I covered for the
sky Dalton is the same as the Joel from
The Last of Us and Deadpool in Deadpool
and the Joker in Arkham like it's insane
how many voices this guy does it's kind
of crazy to imagine if you think about
it there you go
believe me believe it or not look at
look it up you'll see since all the
Gator water hard hat okay one more there
we go you're all gonna [ __ ] die ah
yay angels demons Bros for ChaCha's
bro-chachos Brooke got my rose from my
head I can it's so bad I'm sorry I try
so hard okay God well they [ __ ] 9
didn't they
there we go I find you so still very
dark can't barely see anything what are
you trying to shoot [ __ ] this still
doesn't see me idiot
well two down yeah so the currents are
good at hiding people whoa wait I'm here
choppers man helicopter picks up [ __ ]
the conduits must be inside inside the
helicopters got your roof I am going and
going like nobody's knowing I took out
those up live with that without look at
that it's freaking on battlefield don't
shoot the choppers you're gonna get the
conduits killed whoops oh sure just jump
on the moving shipping containers four
stories off the ground you see this is
the kind of fun stuff you miss when you
stick too much aboard that you're all
there it is go break the winch attach it
under the choppers [ __ ] that'd be
awesome
this is fun
destroy the winch attach to the pit oh
this thing oh okay yeah yeah good up
whoops
hope no one was underneath that haha you
never know
god I want the TV power again give back
the power of TV small cyst will wash all
the asian dramas and ain't nobody
disturb him oh there's another one how
convenient just flying around like it's
nobody's business how do I get up there
here we go whoa Wow your serpent that's
how it's damaging power television it's
not working
oh it is working never mind let's find
another one
look up a Sam oh my god I'm so fast so
fast in so fish for a reason here we go
hey guys what up oh that was close
like I have no regard whatsoever if
there's like a living people in Rooney I
have to check this to be safe if in
weekend kind of funny if someone was
anything for a guy
this is enjoying his morning coffee on
this front on his outdoor porch and he
got some moist by a container where are
you going sir
no don't hide come on ah son of a gun
you breasts think we can do it yep
oh oh oh it's gonna hurt no it didn't
okay well that's what you get for being
smosh's the greatest prophet of the
earth oh there's one more okay I didn't
see that look at that building damn what
did they do
I'm never gonna reach [ __ ] here we go oh
my god can we do it
don't worry dirt yeah oh god oh god that
was close
pinecone what are you doing pinecone
shut up
you don't know me Oh finalmente that was
a mixture of everything
doulton that last containers on the
ground in Denny Park
oh god verging on it now if you can't
let them get those conduit okay where is
it
I'm not letting you have these people
this frickin sword is amazing
Oh got a flyweight fly on the wings a
beaut the pony bah
we better get rid of this um antenna
thing on top
yep English I said it antenna thing on
top samosas we'll have to deal with this
get up yes there you are
samosas power did I do it no it didn't
but that nope well then that gasps I
knew it
what am i this would be a great frisbee
time to subdue them hoes if you know
what I'm saying you don't have to be a
dick join my clan actually you can still
join and be a dick we don't really have
any requirements really though I
required plenty of dicks like you I said
join us alright fine just die your ball
no one likes you anyway hey I'm on your
side
hey Einstein I'm on your side my god
what's in my way oh [ __ ]
ah I haven't got a while gonna use the
ball to once I got in about two minutes
supposed to happen don't flake on me now
man I can't I can't do it your TV come
on chill out relax max no change no no
no stay with me
you T
Eugene come on man please tell me you
did not just leave me at the altar
could he I was shipping them so hard -
all right let's get destroy that and get
some samosas of India's beers oh hey I
was trying to free them but they just
died but my fault there you go you're
all day in not really almost Oh TV power
awesome everything is awesome everything
is cool when you're watching TV when
you're watching foody Pete what took you
good job bear me no he left well what
are you gonna do
well look who decided to join the real
world yeah you convinced me really
figured I'd give people one more chance
well on behalf of people thank you yeah
well we're second happen they let me
down again
I ran hell fire on their asses oh my god
that guy has potential happy thoughts
to be schwag sorry I said it okay almost
level up almost so close god damn it
bros alright let's do some upgrades
I gotta get dis and dis and don't we
don't need that I'm gonna get ya we're
gonna get dad and Darius in da ass and
the other okay there we go
what do we do now our brother is gonna
call in three two one one the TV power
is the awesomest one so far by far far
far oh my gosh you're right they're
scrambling but no one's firing and now
they're ordering all Seattle PD out of
an area near the waterfront something
they don't want anybody to see hope they
don't mind if I take a look it sounds
like they've carpeted the group with a
PCS stick to the rooftops we're too much
okay well let's go there then
investigate the source for great the
views are from up here Isaac fries
brother sightsee later yeah
here we are once again rough first me
don't know once ne'er is everywhere it
looks like my handiwork
so there's another smoke conduit
surprised you I just want to reach no I
guess I was just hoping for something
new
sure my handiwork it's time to take
picture selfie time oh my god Randolph
you look fab today looks smoking hot hey
man they do the same thing to me get the
[ __ ] out thank you preciate it
do you want to subdue I'll take that as
a yes
you just doesn't haven't made up your
mind yet oh you can do that that's
pretty cool man good for you good for
you wait I hear another word okay okay
hello this come on do a minute you're
saying it's that guy Hank I thought you
said she killed him back in salmon bag
she did or I thought she did uh me
I saw her kill him I mean he's dead I'm
sure of it [ __ ] that's a bit strange so
the guy in the beginning is not dead
what the [ __ ]
let's just know there's gonna be a plot
twist it's gonna be a plot twist I can
feel it Russ I feel it in my brother's
ow
I feel it in my bro fierce hello goodbye
good to meet you I'm invisible
who wants to subdue first all right how
about everyone at [ __ ] once your LDN
come get in my bein wait are they not
there we go
okay I was worried there for a second oh
boy that sure was fun sup dude subdued
subdued joined a sniper clan you're
invited you want to join my sorry you're
ugly I don't like you who wants to join
my sniper clan once doing myself McClane
you're not invited so I'm gonna murder
you that's how we do it in the sniper
plane [ __ ] levers continue to invest
giddy IRA for more clothes okay
how about a brief history I'm gonna
admit it I was wrong
what the [ __ ]
what is this keep that early Christmas
gift for you
meet Belson you got a call a girl when
you decide to go on a rampage in
downtown uh that's not me I got a grave
you with somebody smoking the hell out
of Duke chopper but you can see them
where are you on top of a building near
its Walton Union what is going on there
why do you care about this I go
you already got smoked because I think
this might be the guy he was on a
transport with you the one I got my
powers from you mean that big sweaty guy
Hank yes yes and if he busted out of
Augustine's tower then maybe he can help
me figure out a way to break in won't
you come with me and help no no that guy
is bad news I think I'll just you know
sit back and watch the fireworks
Delsin just watch yourself I don't trust
the bulb redneck sure that's racist
ectly helpless all right besides Dena
I've got something in common
got no love for August yeah good luck
Thanks
appreciate it I mean we beat him Lilly
when we had zero powers so I think we'll
be okay rooftop downtown fighting off
choppers all right but listen to me
don't let that do you mean catch him oh
right I got it
don't let them kill him either and don't
you kill don't let him get away
he's been it's a lot to remember yeah I
don't remember half of that your
brother's out alone it's hard being
samosas made so many people want stuff
from you all the time Reggie aloof isn't
mocked
no I didn't lose I'm just keeping my
distance on purpose he can practically
fly man
yeah so can you in three languages
that's a good one it's just a fact he's
through he's totally running away from
this come on come back here you know you
want it
hey guys frickin pimping roofs here hi
how's everyone doing there you are hey
wait I'm not gonna hurt you I just need
you never mind I already have that
where's it going come back here I want a
cuddle
it's been so long I'm not gonna get back
he'll make me yeah come on see I'm here
before he even came here I can agree
your movements son I'm this one it like
paint really so much better than child
Wednesday lucky he's the same chains
because smoked all you want girl you
slow down I just want to talk got
nothing to say to you am I supposed to
kill him I guess then I don't really
wanted to talk there we go alright I
thought it was forever
whoa we're gonna have a smoke off was
the best samosas did he do what I think
he just did
what are you dear to my phone you really
can't take a punch Hank how the hell'd
you get this number
you're listed sorry about the dang with
the sucker punch but knew there was no
talking to your date calm down calm down
man make it my face Oh call you back no
no no wait some I'm calling you sure so
far you've been all about chasing and
shouting and wailing away of me I'm
gonna take Augustine down but I need
your help to do it
I could sign on for something like that
great then we should hold on the dup
guys around here are scrambling
something's up
I'll check it out I'll call you back are
we limiting up oh so close come on come
on man me thank God just appeared on me
sorry look I caught up with Hank he
wants to work with us to get to
Augustine oh I'm not sure that's a good
idea man oh no what did whether you
worry too much
maybe you just don't worry enough that's
it yeah careful watch your back worry
too much not enough ego
yes we did it we're maxed out awesome
we're a Paragon one step closer becoming
arrows so next step is Hiro probably
that's pretty awesome can't wait to
skate and hate potat mate that's all I
got really
I'm still trying to be a rapper though
so don't more inviting it's gonna happen
it's an evidence it's an epidemic it's
an it will happen
hello friends family but did it
helicopter go swear to god oh god damn
it
oh yeah damn we're gonna have to be
bolder whoops yeah
ah yes circus the power suppose is too
strong like why do they even try could
this be it oh my god there it is how did
I not see this there you go
took me three hours Rose don't don't
even worry about it now it's open hello
high five time please I waited for you
[ __ ]
dami goose blow that tower up below that
tower up why does it explode there you
go now we're blew up high five just
break it down now to me now go now sorry
sorry I'll slap there we go finally we
can start this mission fantastic what's
up when you chase me cross those
buildings with all the helicopters and
all before tell me yeah sorry about all
that no I was just gonna say you clearly
been getting the hang of those smoke
tricks I gave well you know I I kind of
need you to teach me one more you
managed to escape her tower once how'd
you get past those electrified
barricades that's a trade school roof
across the way you gotta shut down but
it ain't gonna do you no good she got
the whole thing armored up and half the
dup for sustaining guard right but maybe
if we both work together
my specialties breaking out of places
like Stan not in listen we both got our
reasons for getting Augustin she got
something each of us wants but we gotta
do it on our terms not hers we got to
draw her out of her castle and out here
where we stayed too changed any ideas
well you know them two kids it was on
the armored bus with me fetching Eugene
I guess
anyway do you he's got what just after
that was all the commotion before guess
you needed to reel him in to make up for
me getting loose she sent him after that
big concrete platform to DUP bill
between the two islands then we gotta
help now there's a pier right across
from that platform
meet me there just after sunset I'll be
there should be pretty soon Reggie let's
do some upgrades porchettos I haven't
gal Eugene infested I heard I heard Hank
and I we've worked out a plan to storm
the island and take out whatever dudes
are guarding them and nothing I've been
thinking there have been a lot of
innocent people killed lately normal
people normal Jesus we're not going back
to that are we I'm not sure I can help
you add to that count right just set a
couple of bioterrorist free it's yeah
I'm a cop I'm supposed to prevent this
kind of thing just give me a call when
it's over remove head back to salmon bed
can't wait watch out for Hank don't
trust it do you trust anyone I think it
does
you
and we're back what is gonna happen here
reg root what are you doing here look
those are people over there they need
our help
not bio terrorists not conduits people
well thank you
and thank you for being so what's cop
doing here he's my brother okay he's
he's here from so what do you think I've
been doing some recon our best bets the
dock on the far side less exposed figure
you two can do your smoke gift
thank you draw their attention up front
I'll come into your boat and go in
during the distraction why are you going
in first
because I'm a cop which means I can
commandeer a boat it's legal ha ha ha ha
haul your ass in oh he'll do it too
um so we'll see you inside right yeah
see you inside boy all the bird it's
like ah don't touch me ah stop making
noise Agustin will come running come on
I know way into the island we won't be
seen explain what happened I saw
Augustin kill you back and you saw her
shut me up
you saw you should've brought the cop
man
that's a mistake huh funny that the same
thing about you alright we need to
follow Hank shouldn't be hard
it's me have that superior power I mean
samosas is amazing don't get me wrong
girl or boy here she is we pop in here
should come out smack dab in the middle
of the thing you sure about this hey
when I was in that tower I saw things
one more thing
they got one of them drone things out
there the ones you get powers from you
know about that sure would be nice to
get a new power before stomping on
Augustine let's go
does look pretty badass when you're
Hans's oh ow oh there was here okay
there we go
samosas for life okay you're sorry we
start cracking these support pillars
they feel the rumble and the guards come
down and check it out we'll take them
out in August Eve how would I tell you
sorry didn't trust you man
damn straight damn straight you guys
want to subdue to my sniper clan
seriously though you guys should
consider it at least how about you yeah
you're good Oh shit's happening what you
get from messing with a prom idiot now
don't shoot my him in the ass
he needs that for my sniper client come
on stop shooting my supposed to say act
like it Ken everything glitch somewhere
in that sentence yeah come back hello
good night
sniper clean no it's not dead what what
god I hate these guys
I did it and not you there you go all
right and see this one whoa how many
more
whoops doesn't matter you're all day
let's finish these yeah match wait
another one she should be here any
minute all right
hurry over here and let's see what
powers you did oh my god this place has
floors
what all of a sudden you don't trust me
I don't know man something's not right
maybe I should call Reggie uh you didn't
disappoint me I did like you asked you
just do like you promised oh my god
trusted you
never trust a convict I see we found
something in your size but just to be
sure
uh hi my brother finds out what you did
oh he's gonna he's gonna what ha ha ha
ha oh my god you couldn't hit me back
for blasting me with the Angels
come on guess Emma's okay it was awesome
oh [ __ ] oh not that way maybe I press
I'm sorry but I'm gonna have to end that
episode there hope you enjoyed watching
if you did as always thanks for leaving
like it helps me out a lot
and it makes me do this every episode
how awesome were you for doing that
it really thanks figuring out with me
today and stay awesome press Rafi